[Música]
bienvenidos a este episodio especial
información en todo lo que se hizo para el
semana de prensa en la escuela
francia con los alumnos del segundo ce
escuela secundaria paul valery en paris en autoexamen
positivo al cuento de madera del grifo
necesita una explicación
vamos a hacer una prueba para ver el
primera barrera o quien se muestra es
normal aquí hay dos barras así que probado
positivo con agua del grifo
viene y tesco rapido da miedo
el agua ya ha dado positivo, así que
barrer una preocupación por hacer de todos modos
le muestra a la otra tesis que muestra
un resultado positivo con agua de la
toque desde principios de enero este tipo de
los videos estan circulando en tik tok twitter o
facebook se han visto algunos videos
comienzo del mes
con esta experiencia algunos
Los internautas nos harán creer que el
coc u19 sobre el presente en el agua del
grifo y que las autopruebas no pueden
así que videos similares no son confiables
se han realizado en otros países
sala de gripe legal es positivo para
relleno triple korite y absoluta
los sacrificios harán un duro y
intereses matrimoniales positivos a la ley de
vamos a garabatear entonces para comprobar el rumor
hicimos preguntas
virología
es posible que el significado
positivo si si pones long du
Caucásico quieres probarlo
no está hecho para eso modificará el
parámetros de prueba es injusto una prueba
colorimétrico con una oxidación por lo tanto
si quieres en este momento es
ya no vale si pongo agua en estos
instrumentos positivos y despues de covin
infeccioso en el agua durante
como para contener fragmentos de un ARN
desde el coville es posible sobre todo el
alcantarillado y agua del grifo
no hay ninguno sin ni siquiera en las aguas residuales
no hay virus infeccioso porque
que es un virus envuelto por lo que
se degrada rápidamente en el medio
afuera y no hay manera
transmitir coville por agua
alguna prueba usada alguna
¿Cómo podemos sesgarlo?
También preguntó si es este tipo de
los videos tienen un impacto en la opinión
público
y luego el principio hay fallas que
noticias de problemas y redes sociales
es que todo el mundo tiene una opinión sobre
todo y la mayoría de las personas que eres
Lesard spot 2 no existe por lo tanto
conclusión de experimentos en lucknow ne
no encontramos nada usamos una autocomprobación incorrectamente
puedes obtener cualquier resultado
y no cerrado no puede ser positivo
al cuerpo 19
era info o intoxicacion con los estudiantes de
los segundos 5 del liceo paul valery